مقاطعه الصفقت على واقع اليم سقط عشرات
القتلى والجرحى جراء قصف صاروخيا روسي
استهدف وسط هذه المدينه وتحديدا المنطقه
السكنيه التي يمكن ان نشاهدها
الذي حصل هنا سقط الصاروخ الاول في ساعات
المساء وقتل على اثره شخص واصيب اكثر من
سبعه بجراح عندما وصلت فرق الانقاذ الى
هذه المنطقه تحديدا وبشرت عمليات ازاله
الركام ومحاوله انقاص واخراج الجرحى
والمصابين والضحايا سقط صاروخ ثاني مما
ادى الى مقتل واصابه العشرات يمكن ان
نشاهد حجم الدمار الذي خلفه الصاروخ
الثاني في هذا المبنى وهو فندق في وسط
المدينه
وفق السلطات الاوكرانيه الصواريخ التي تم
استخدامها في استهداف هذه المنطقه هي من
طراز اسكندر هذا ما اكدته السلطات هنا
المحليه وايضا على مستوى رئاسه الجمهوريه
الاوكرانيه التي اكدت بان هذا القصف ياتي
من خلال صواريخ استخدامتها اقوات الروسيه
لاستهداف الوسط المدني في هذه المدينه حجم
الدمار واضح ضمن ركعتين كبيره
السيارات المباني المضره المتضرره كلها
هنا في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا حاولت قوى الامن
فرض طوق امني على هذه المنطقه الخبراء
اخرجوا البقايا المرتبطه بالصواريخ وتم
نقلها قبل قليل عمليا
المنازل والسكان الذين تضرروا بجراء هذا
القصف يمكن ان نشاهد بعضا منهم وقد يحصون
الاضرار التي اصابت
منازلهم ومساكنهم وقد مات القصف يتكرر
بشكل دائم في كل هذه المناطق الواقعه في
مقاطعه مسجد ابراهيم الجزيره بوكوروس
اوكرانيا